this video was made possible by
curiositystream when you sign up at
curiositystream.com Wendover you'll also
get access to nebula the streaming video
platform that Wendover is a part of
there's a battle going on in the Pacific
the People's Republic of China and the
Republic of China more commonly known as
Taiwan have fought their territorial
dispute for Generations but now nearly
each and every one of the tiny Nations
dotting the Pacific Ocean has emerged as
a battlefield for this conflict the
weapons of this war are not guns and
bullets but rather concrete and
banknotes this is a diplomatic Mission
aiming to shore up the support of some
of the world's smallest countries
there are 14 nations in question here
Palau Papua New Guinea the Federalist
States of Micronesia the Solomon Islands
nauru Vanuatu the Marshall Islands Fiji
tuvalu Tonga kiribas Samoa Nui and the
Cook Islands with the exception of Papua
New Guinea each of these have
populations below 1 million and each
also tends to have fairly low GDP per
capitas generally between one and five
thousand dollars this means that they're
each granted fairly significant amounts
of foreign aid in the previous decade
Nui for example received 134 million
dollars in Aid or about 83 thousand
dollars for each member of its
population
region-wide that average is only in the
low thousands but the point is that the
Pacific gets a lot of Aid now most of
this does not come from Taiwan or China
Australia is by far the largest donor it
is important for Australia to be in
these countries good graces for
strategic reasons for example six
percent of Australia's GDP is made up
solely of exports that take one of these
three Maritime routes Each of which
passes by some of these specific
countries these trade routes could be
disrupted if there were instability in
the Pacific political stability also
keeps 4 foreign powers from attempting a
power grab in any one of these nations
and any such power grab would likely be
too close for comfort for Australia so
the primary Aid motivation for Australia
and its close allies like New Zealand
and the US is stability that is not the
primary motivation for China and Taiwan
these two powers are openly engaging in
what's known as checkbook diplomacy
they're buying diplomatic Partners
through financial aid but why China is a
massive nation of more than a billion
people what benefit does it receive from
having tiny Nations like Samoa Tonga or
Fiji on its side well they might gain
some limited benefit but the main reason
China Works to build these diplomatic
Partnerships is so Taiwan cannot that's
because to Taiwan even a tiny 11 000
person Nation like tuvalu is hugely
valuable as tuvalu has something Taiwan
doesn't tuvalu is a member of the United
Nations
Taiwan is rarely recognized as an
independent country in international
settings this is despite the fact that
in almost every way it acts and operates
as an independent country would there
are plenty of countries like the US for
example that have strong relations with
Taiwan and treat it as if it were a
country the U.S has a de facto Embassy
in Taiwan recognizes Taiwanese passports
sells military supplies to Taiwan and
has an enormously strong trade
relationship with Taiwan yet it does not
recognize Taiwan as a country that's
because in international relations there
is an implicit rule you either recognize
the Republic of China or the People's
Republic of China now given the choice
between working with the world's most
populous country or a moderately sized
island of 24 million nearly every nation
picks China even though Taiwan and the
US are functionally allies while China
and the US are Frenemies at best it's
just not worthwhile for the US to
recognize Taiwan as a country this is
the case for almost every country that
is of course unless Taiwan makes it
worthwhile across the Pacific Taiwan has
been funding projects to keep small
Nations on its side in Palau they spent
1.3 million dollars to help the country
recover from Typhoon Haiyan in Papua New
Guinea they spent 4.5 million dollars to
improve domestic agriculture in order to
increase food Security in the Solomon
Islands they spent 2.5 million dollars
to train local staff and conduct a
survey of the Island's local plant
species in nauru they spent 600 thousand
dollars donating more efficient compact
fluorescent light bulbs to local
households in the Marshall Islands they
spent one million dollars building a sea
wall around magro atoll to protect it
from rising sea levels in Fiji they
spent three hundred thousand dollars
improving Mental Health Service access
around the country in tuvalu they spent
two hundred thousand dollars repairing
and improving water storage equipment
around the country after a cyclone in
kiribos they spent 19 million dollars to
repair and upgrade the country's main
airport
each of these projects and the hundreds
more funded by Taiwan around the Pacific
improves its relations with these
countries and therefore brings it more
and more diplomatic clout Taiwan can't
afford to buy the support of large
Nations but in some settings the size of
the nation doesn't matter in the United
Nations General Assembly for example
it's one country one vote it doesn't
matter if it's tuvalu or China when
voting every member nation has the exact
same power there are other systems in
the U.N where power is more balanced
based on population but overall the
world's smallest nations have a
disproportionate amount of power more
recognition even by the smallest
countries strengthens taiwan's case for
a position in intergovernmental
organizations like the UN that's why
Taiwan targets small Nations for support
five million dollars spent on tuvalu
goes a lot further than 5 million
dollars spent on Mexico for example but
in the general assembly tuvalu can help
Taiwan just as much as Mexico can this
diplomatic clout that Taiwan has amassed
though gets in the way of China's
ambition of eventually unifying the two
it is for that reason that the People's
Republic has gone on the offensive China
has been courting taiwan's diplomatic
Partners in the Pacific with Promises of
larger Aid packages the most recent two
defectors were kiribos and the Solomon
Islands early in the 2010s China
provided no foreign aid to either of
these countries but then as soon as they
each revoked their recognition of Taiwan
Promises of planes ferries medical
supplies and more started pouring in
from China in addition to these two
countries Taiwan has lost diplomatic
support from the Dominican Republic
Burkina Faso El Salvador Panama and
santome and Principe since 2016. that
leaves them with just 15 total
diplomatic partners and only four in the
Pacific region to maintain the limited
support that it has Taiwan has had to
get tactical China's Style with Aid is
to build big flashy expensive
infrastructure projects in Fiji they
spend 50 million dollars building a
paved road that halved the time it took
for local farmers to get to markets but
local Engineers reportedly said that a
far lower quality and cheaper Road could
have achieved the same result in Vanuatu
they spent 80 million dollars upgrading
a port to allow for larger cruise ships
to dock but in all of 2019 for example
just five visited in Papua New Guinea
they spent one million dollars building
a malaria Hospital in the capital of
Port Moresby despite that being the
region of the country with the least
malaria and despite the capital having
no Road link to the regions with the
worst malaria outbreaks each of these
projects and more clearly have positive
effects but undoubtedly they are not the
most efficient uses of 1 or 50 or 80
million dollars in the mission of
improving relations between China and
these Pacific Nations China does big
flashy and sometimes ineffective Aid
Taiwan does small personable and
generally more effective Aid that's why
they have been able to maintain the
relationships they have for so long
despite a much lower budget China Works
to impress the governments Taiwan Works
to impress the people taiwan's average
Aid project size in the Pacific is five
hundred thousand dollars China's is six
million dollars Taiwan does things like
contribute sixteen hundred dollars for
palau's baseball team to attend a
tournament in Guam or spend 200 000
buying a boat for an outer out hole in
the Marshall Islands or construct three
hundred thousand dollars of solar street
lights in nauru the 80 million dollar
port in Vanuatu might help people more
than the sixteen hundred dollars for the
baseball team in Palau but one can be
sure that every member of that team and
their families and friends heard about
and remember how Taiwan helped them
that's less likely with the large
somewhat ineffective Port Taiwan knows
that the choice of which side to support
is a political issue in the Pacific
because there is that choice pretty much
any politician in these countries will
run their campaign with the Taiwan issue
as part of their platform and so Taiwan
is trying to gain the support of
everyday people they want to win support
from the ground up rather than from the
top down this might create a better
value for their money but at the end of
the day China just has so so much more
money if China wants to win the
political support of a small nation they
can just spend and spend and spend at
this point taiwan's few tiny diplomatic
partners are no longer a threat to
China's goal of reunification China will
likely keep courting these nations not
because they need to but because it'll
further weaken Taiwan eventually though
if there comes a day when the Taiwan
issue is resolved either through
reunification or recognized Independence
the Pacific Islands will be victims
because when they're no longer useful
the pawn is the first to be sacrificed
if you want to learn more about one of
the four Pacific island nations that are
still on taiwan's side the Marshall
Islands you can watch the nebula
exclusive documentary we filmed on
location in the Marshall Islands you
heard earlier that Taiwan funded a sea
wall for the capital mazuro but the
final years of Majuro explains why that
was necessary and what it means for the
nation it explains what life is like in
a nation with an expiration date the
best way to get access to that is to
sign up for curiosity streams nebula
bundle deal curiosity stream is of
course home to thousands of
documentaries that any Wendover viewer
will enjoy and nebula is home to all of
wendover's normal videos early and
ad-free plus special exclusive projects
like this documentary what's more it's
not only Wendover on there but half as
interesting real engineering BrainCraft
tier Zoo real life lore and more and
more of your favorite educational
creators so once again sign up for any
subscription at triositystream.com
Wendover for as little as 20 dollars a
year and get access to nebula for free